when you were writing the script did you
have people in mind I mean you have also
Peter Bogdanovich with the project I
mean did you have specific people did
you know Cheryl was going to be again
because it was so personal I just had
myself and my family in mind like I
wasn't I wasn't projecting anyone but
but them onto it but that's what's fun
about it is that you i have no i believe
me three years ago i did not know that
i'd be sitting in a chair next to share
plans talking about a movie called cold
turkey where she plays my mother like
you know that's what's great is that i
just wrote it in a broom to cheat him i
friggin iphone like I didn't care but
people like the script and so here we
are and how did you get it into the
appropriate hands can you Tom really
really good casting director named Paul
ready knew all these agents and you all
these managers knew Larry new fad Larry
David Larry yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
was all through him I don't know anyone
I you know I'm some guy in a basement
scribbling away about my life and he
just had all these connections and all
these all these folks came in and read
and met and and I was it so were there
times within that three years that it
looked like it wasn't going to happen oh
it's funny oh of course I mean the thing
got pushed 17 times and fell apart 18
times and all that but honestly it
happened pretty quick I wrote it in
early 2011 and we shot in early 2012 and
we're sitting here and you know mid to
late 2013 which is quick for a movie
that is great thanks guys thank you
you